welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and while the spider-man no way home
post-credit scene with tom hardy's venom
sets up a reborn peter parker with an
exciting new black birthday suit for
spider-man 4 a lot of venom fans were
understandably a little bit shocked to
see eddie and venom quickly leave the
mcu universe without eating at least one
person or at the very least leaving a
tip for the bartender who just recapped
the entirety of the infinity saga for
your rude drunk ass like where the hell
were you venom lady liberty needed her
lethal loogie while your lips were loose
with liquor well according to no way
home writers chris mckenna and eric
summers in the recent interview with
variety the people who love to spoil
comic book movies i don't know why they
do that please stop while eddie in
venom's mtu cameo was ultimately cut
short having sony's odd couple play a
role in the greatest spider-man team-up
of all time at the statue of liberty was
something that was definitely discussed
during production which means that we
the people of the speculation nation
must speculate on just how this scene
could have gone down so let's dive into
it my nerd babies this video is brought
to you by squarespace from websites and
online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business okay so
at the end of venom let there be carnage
after venom stuffs his stomach with his
herald sun at the wedding reception
venom just casually brings up his
multiversal hive mind that he's always
had access to during honeymoon pillow
talk with his husband eddie are you
you hiding stuff from me
80 billion light years of hive knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain and then we see venom and
eddie's hotel accommodations drastically
upgraded after magic rick and morty
dubba dub dubbed the runes of kafka
spell that sends eddie and venom to the
mcu that we all know and love and
according to these same writers as we've
long expected here on new rockstars the
reason why eddie and venom were
transported to the mcu along with doc
ock green goblin electric django and all
those other people who knew peter parker
was spider-man was because the idea is
that the symbiote has knowledge of other
universes buried in his brain is some
knowledge of that connection this means
that at least one venom symbiote within
the marvel live-action multiverse had
that specific knowledge of peter
parper's identity as spider-man
specifically sam raimi's version from
spider-man 3 who perished via a
devastating combo of banging pots and
pans and the power of friendship also a
bomb but you know mostly the power of
friendship and i believe that it is
because of these very memories of rainy
venom lodged within hardy venom's
multiversal hive subconscious that venom
felt the urge and compulsion to lick the
screen at the very sight of tom hall and
peter parker but not because tom holland
is a handsome man like i initially
assumed from the very first introduction
of the reimu venom symbiote at the
beginning of spider-man 3 that very same
symbiote has been obsessed with the
radioactive nature of tobey maguire
peter parker's biology and having tobey
maguire peter parker be the very first
human host it latched onto after
arriving on this new strange planet was
literally like hitting the lottery for
this rude goo dude because peter was
pretty much the most evolved person on
his planet i mean as far as we know
anyway and this is why the symbiote was
a hardcore stage five clinger when toby
wanted to break up with him after sunday
night church and decided to bond with
eddie brock instead a man intent on the
death of peter parker i want you to kill
peter parker because at the end of the
day if the symbiote couldn't bond with
peter he was for sure going to absorb
his weird spider-man energy by eating
that goofy nerd because
why not
if 2022 is the year you finally start
your own business squarespace is the
only one platform to build a beautiful
online presence for that business the
kind of presence that makes your old
boss wish you hadn't left and regret
accidentally eating your lunch from the
company fridge that one time squarespace
lets you present members only gated
content connect your social media
accounts presents video content and all
other cool features to give you a super
cool super functional website for your
hobby or your business squarespace will
even sell you a url which is really
awesome collect the emails of interested
folks and send custom newsletters to
keep them up to date on what you're
doing and all the cool new business
stuff that you're up to head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com new rockstars for 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain and we thank squarespace for
sponsoring this video so knowing all of
this i think it would make sense to
glean that if john watts in marvel
studios decided to integrate tom hardy's
venom within that final battle in no way
home it would likely be alongside no way
home's fearsome five to make a truly
sinister sick showdown at the statue of
liberty because the end of venom let
there be carnage marked the very
beginnings of eddie and venom's decision
to fully embrace the title of lethal
protector so what better way to do that
than to go after jay jonah jameson's
public enemy number one who also happens
to be the most delicious snack your
subconscious hive mind and zendaya have
ever seen so i'm speculating that one of
marvel studios plans for tom hardy and
venom was to have tom hardy and venom
accidentally join the sinister six
because they mistake them for the
avengers that the bartender was talking
to them about while they were drunk
so that combined with venom's immense
cosmic thirst for peter's teenage body
which is very weird would definitely
justify this heroic venom variant's
actions against spider heroes huey dewey
and louis before norman of course puts
the lime in the coconut that is the box
and twist the multiverse all up and that
is usually the point where one lethal
protector would tend to realize that the
lethal protector was on the wrong side
of multiversal history when the cracks
appear in the sky that's how you know to
switch sides
and that's what he would do at that
point he would switch sides to aid his
new spider brothers to cure and help out
the rest of those refugees of the mcu
spider-verse and my god would it have
been super cool to see all four of them
doing their thing together and for venom
to be inspired by those three spiderman
and like donning the symbol that would
be really cool however i very much
understand why marvel studios did the
things the way they did in no way home
for one having venom introduced in the
final battle as a spider-man enemy might
not be the best way for a lot of
audiences unfamiliar with this new venom
to get to know that character because
it's just a bad first impression like
sony has been trying to sell venom as a
good guy for the longest time despite
venom's claim to fame being one of
spider-man's greatest foes in the comics
so though his actions against the
spider-man would be justified in this
scenario where he mistakes them as
enemies of the avengers it's just not
the best first impression to give a lot
of people and secondly and most
importantly in my opinion i think the
mcu just wants tom hall and peter parker
to go through a comic accurate retelling
of his first interactions with the
symbiote suit in spider-man 4. however
mcu peter parker can't really go through
that discovery if he has just a full-on
run-in with both tom hardy's venom and
toby maguire spider-man who could both
just give peter the full lowdown on just
what this black goo that toby maguire
brought up earlier even is i just think
that kevin feige amy pascal and all the
people involved just figured that it'd
be a lot more fun if peter parker had to
just figure out his emo stage of puberty
in every spider-man's life by himself
well you know by himself with the help
of a little friend by the name of reed
richards of the fantastic four who we
know are coming to the mcu very soon and
is the very person in the comics who
reveals to peter what the symbiote even
is like i would put a million dollars on
all of us getting to see a bombastic
bagman spider-man in the mcu very soon
because i'm sure emo peter would
definitely want to end his biochemical
romance with venom after a piece of news
like that were to come from a smart man
like reed richards uh peter your suits
trying to kill you he's sucking your
life out of you he's making you evil
take it off thank you dr richards i
should not have touched it
but that is how i think venom would have
been integrated within that final scene
in spider-man no way home again i'm very
happy with what we got but i am curious
as to what you guys think would have
happened so let us know what you think
in the comment section below but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me on twitter at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly follow new rockstars on
youtube twitter wherever we are so you
can keep up with the new rockstars
conversation at all times and of course
hit up new rockstars.com so you can get
cool shirts like this but again thank
you guys so much for watching i'll see
you guys later i love you guys so much
goodbye
[Music]
you